[Music]
this morning on the dish chef and
restaurateur daniel holzman early in his
career he had some of the finest
training one could ask for at elite
restaurants and cooking schools but
instead of oat cuisine he decided to
focus on everyday foods people love that
includes the once lowly meatball the
centerpiece of his chain of new york
city-based restaurants and his latest
venture danny boy's pizza in los angeles
now he's out with a new book food iq
featuring 100 essential cooking
questions and answers jamie wax has his
story
now that's an ideal patty shape and size
i think that's an ideal patty shape and
size i really do because we're gonna
have two of these remember yeah chef
daniel holzman finds inspiration
everywhere even in a perfectly cooked
cheeseburger we're just going to double
double lift them off
right on top of that bun bottom
that's like a five minute
bundle of joy
my god that's good and though he's best
known for unpretentious crowd-pleasing
cuisine he developed his skills in some
of the most refined french kitchens in
the world
i mean you started out as a kid in high
school in new york in the kitchen of
eric repair at la bernadine my best
friend's father was the maitre d got me
a job there i remember my first day eric
interviews me and he was just an
absolutely extraordinary mentor and i
learned so much about discipline in life
love for food and respect for people
qualities he took with him to the
culinary institute of america and into
the kitchen of another famous french
chef jean-louis paladin
so my goal was to be on the cover food
magazine you know four-star fancy chef
and at some point i realized that the
people that i love and hang out with and
care about can't afford to eat this food
and i want to cook the you know food
that speaks to me so you know there's no
reason that a hot dog a meatball a slice
of pizza shouldn't have the same level
of quality as a fancy steak or a piece
of fish at a fancy restaurant in 2010 a
life-changing opportunity presented
itself you were out west and you get a
call how did the meatball shop start so
my best friend michael chernow he calls
me up he says i want to open this
restaurant i want you to be the chef and
at the time i had not intended to move
back to new york at all the meatball
shop was exactly that that moment when
we said we're going to give up our goal
of being fancy chefs our goal of being
in magazines we're just going to try and
give something back to the community and
maybe open a restaurant that that speaks
to us
holzman grew up in new york city his
first love for cooking came from inside
his home
my mom was a fantastic cook and anything
i was interested in she was cooking with
me we were making pasta hanging off of
the backs of chairs together and you
know to dry and making pizzas and breads
at home do you mind grabbing me a rack a
dough bud
so it's no surprise that all these years
later he's making pizza again this time
in l.a at his place danny boy's famous
original pizza a venture inspired by him
and his wife we were sitting on the
couch and we were we had a few drinks
the night before and we're thinking we
need a what are we craving a slice of
pizza and you know there's so much great
pizza in los angeles but there wasn't uh
uh an example of what i
the that that childhood memory of great
new york style pizza that
that satisfies your soul in a way that
nothing else can right
and so that's what we set out to do open
a great new york style pizzeria
nothing more and now he's poured his
knowledge and experience into a new book
food iq 100 questions answers and
recipes to raise your cooking smarts
created with acclaimed food writer matt
rodbard when i read this book i think
about the fact that being a professional
chef must be a little bit like being a
doctor like at cocktail parties people
come up and ask you questions that they
don't quite know or that don't really
exist in other types of cookbooks our
number one goal was how can we demystify
break it down and say read this book
cook better speak you know smarter about
food and just understand what's going on
in a way that gives you confidence to
cook and talk about food we sampled some
of the dishes and lessons contained in
the book starting with his signature
pork meatballs
the amount of spice and cheese to me to
breading in this is always what i find
so perfect about your meatballs they are
the texture is just fantastic
i feel like folks you know they think
meat's the most expensive meat's the
best so i'm gonna put a lot of meat in
there and it's counterintuitive but the
more bread the more filler kind of the
better
other dishes included spaghetti alio
olio excellent simple ingredient the
brightness and the fresh flavor of of
the finer olive oil you use as you say
as the sauce basically it's garlic and
it's excellent olive oil and cheese
crispy roasted brussels sprouts brussels
sprouts have very little sugar and so
you can really cook them until they're
until they're almost burnt and it brings
out the sweetness whole salt roasted
onions the sharpness you get in an onion
comes from sulfur and when you cook the
onion the sulfur dissipates and you left
with the sweetness and for dessert
classic chocolate chip cookies how's it
going guys can i get for you and though
he still has plenty of questions daniel
holtzman just might have found the
answer to what brings him satisfaction
in life right now i'm making pizza it's
making me happy that's i know it's a
crazy thing to say but i go in there
every day i stretch pies i put the sauce
on there i watch the cheese melt i feed
it to people it makes them happy it
sounds very pure in most jobs and most
things in life it takes years to see
anything come to fruition the
satisfaction that you get of from
finishing a project like you know just
washing the dishes you're done they're
clean you put them away and you think
i've accomplished something in my day i
get to experience that
three four hundred times a day every
single customer that walks in gets a
slice of pizza that feedback loop is so
tight that i don't know for me that
that's that's kind of all you need to
feel happy
for cbs saturday morning jamie wax
venice california
very nice very nice because already i'm
almost done we typically wait until
after the piece airs just i know i know
elaine and michelle and then i had to
join you too like you guys are
immediately digging in 15 seconds it was
great oh i didn't realize there was a
formal protocol involved jeff floor no
jeff's always
yummy
um look at this though it's right
spectacular did this look great marcy
thank you for all this thank you marcie
welcome marcy's here helping to the dish
master yes um coordinating all this wow
it looks really great and you know we've
heard this from so many chefs in the
past couple years is that they just want
to open a place and strip away all the
extra junk right and they just want to
make real food for real people right and
i love the fact that he has trained
literally at the highest levels eric
repair mary institute of america but
what does he want to do he chooses to
use that mastery of his craft to make it
more accessible to more people and and
meatballs by the way so comforting
especially at this hour in the morning
at 8 30 and brussels sprouts highly
recommend it everyone so good